בוקר טוב.
יום יום חמישי.
השבעה
בחודש מאפריל.
הם בסדר.
ואנחנו בביתו של מר נמרוד ושב
רחוב טאגור
התווים שלך
בטרם נשמע את סיפורך.
בטרם נשמע את הסיפור,
תספר לי בבקשה לשורשיהם.
סליחה ממך
אחים אחיות.
אבא שלי ואמא שלי היו מהמחזור השמיני
של גימנסיה הרצליה.
הם באו.
אמא שלי באה עם כל משפחתה.
היית ילדה קטנה.
ואבא שלי בא בן
שלוש
לבדו
מפולין, רוסיה
באותה תקופה.
אז זה
הם היו חברים. מי הדיון אסיה.
עד יומם האחרון,
אבא שלי.
היא
הצטרף לארגון השומר
בגיל מאוד צעיר. אבל הסיבה הייתה שפרצה מלחמת העולם
מעורב ששלחו לו כסף ללמוד בגימנסיה
ונשאו נותר ללא מקור המחיה.
אז הוא התחיל בתור שומר בקרומי זכרון יעקב.
שם הוא הכיר את אנשי השומר הידועים שלא נחזור להם. רשימה ידועה.
ו
זה התחלת
המעמד
של
הערכה.
פעילות כל חייו.
גם בהגנה ועקומת הפלמ ח. וכל הדברים
האלה.
כן.
מה היה שמו של
יושע?
אייזק
הימים אהפך
ו
אמא שלי היתה
לשם ציון פחות או יותר.
אחותו של אליהו גלום.
והיא הובאה ארצה כילדה עם משפחתה,
אומרים חברים. כל השנים
הם הקימו. היו בין מקימי
גדוד העבודה
ומקימי תל יוסף.
ולמעשה הם ימשיכו בדרך הזאת
עד זה.
אז
בחור קטן.
ואיזה קנה תם?
מה היה שמה של אמך שלומית
ו
אבא שלי.
בהיררכיה של ההגנה
הוא
הגיע, נאמר
לדרגה
של אחד.
אחר כך, כשקמה המדינה, זה אחד משלושת
האלופים הראשונים.
ככה זה. הוא היה גם
חבר בכל הוועדות ואת
הגוף. עם
שני אלו
הוא מרגיש על אליהו גולומב, גם זה
שניהלו את כל ענייני הביטחון,
ההגנה
של
היישוב העברי בארץ ישראל. היה לו תפקיד מוגדר. כן,
הוא היה. הוא היה
חברתו. טיפסת בדיוק התאריכים.
אני לא זוכר, אבל הוא טיפס
עד הדרגה,
שאחד משלושת
היו הארץ חולקה לשלושה מחוזות,
והוא היה מפקד
לפני. זה בדרך,
אני אומר. מהתפקידים הבריאותיים
היה בשעתו טיילור לארגן את עניין
גדר הצפון,
המפקד. הכל המבצע הזה אפשר גדול
מהצד של ההגנה, לא מהצד של סולל בונה.
לו
הוא היה, הוא היה מצד ההגנה ואחראי על כל
הייתה. הבעיה היתה האבטחה. סולל בונה
ידע לעבוד גם
בעצמו
ו
כן,
כך ממשיך למעשה
כל החיים שהוא. אחד הוא ידם
חקלאי. הוא ממשפחה חקלאית.
ברור שהיה להם משק גדול, ממש גדול מאוד.
יש לך שונים? אני זוכר. היו
חלוצים שהיו באים ארצה, היו מביאים
מתנות וכל מיני
מהמשק.
זה
הוא גם נשאר חקלאי.
הוא עצמו
הגיע לדרגה, הוא היה בהנהלת, יכין
יכין חק ל.
הוא היה אחראי על פרדסים חדשים.
זה הייתה ההתמחות שלו.
כל הפרדסים שפרוסים בארץ. אני מכיר אותם
ככף ידי
ו
הסידור היה כזה
מסיבות תקציביות
להגנה
לא היה תקציב להחזיק את אנשי הסגל,
אז תמיד היינו מסדרים דבר כזה. לדוגמה, כמו שהוא היה
שהוא היה עובד,
יכין חק,
העניין ועד ההנהלה ועד אז,
אה,
מפעם לפעם,
לפי הצורך,
היו מורידים אותו מהעבודה.
ואז בבית ידענו ש
שהתקציב חצי.
הם מקבל משהו
כשאפשר היה חוזר בעבודה וכן,
ולפעמים גם תקופות מסוימות
היתה חפיפה.
אמא שלי היתה
תעשייה ממנו בשנתיים
היא
השתתפה בקורס הראשון
שהיה בארץ,
בעל המקצוע שהביא אותו לנו. בניית הסוד
מגרמניה
זה מה שהיו קורים אז עבודה סוציאלית.
כל המנגנון הזה.
אמו של אמא שלי, גם לונדה בקורס הראשון,
וגם היתה אחר כך
ככה. לכן לו לסירוגין גם היו מעבירים אותנו,
אבל זה זה עסקה עם או שלילי
גם כן הצידה.
איפהג עוררתם
בכלל
בו?
כן,
זאת אומרת בהתחלה בטלי
בתל יוסף,
אחר כך הם רוב היו בין מקימי
תנועת הפועלים
ליד בית הכרם
בירושלים,
ו
ואחר כך
אז אנו לפנות בוקר. בני, שאמא של
אמא שלי,
סבתא שלי,
היה לה שומש,
הקימה שם אש.
אז לגמרי לבד. זה היה קשה. אז
אמא שלך
ואבא שלי לא? כן?
מה הזיכרון הראשון שלך?
מתי אתה לא נולדת
אלף
וחמש
אני מתה על יוסף. לא זוכר
כי הייתי ילד קטן
שוב. את זה אני יודע. אבל
במקום הוא שוטה,
אבל חלם ישמן ברחו.
יש לך אחים? אחיות? כן,
יש לי אחות ביח.
כן,
שוב. אבל בואו
זו הייתה השכונות הפועלים הראשונה
שהוקמה על ידי ההסתדרות
כולו.
השחומה
המיוחדת באמת מיוחדת.
ואת
היה כיף לגדול שלנו.
אז אתה ואת אז באמצע התמחור להצניע בחוק,
אתה
אז
את החינוך אחר לשאול אתה מקבל לגבות בשכונה ברחוב
ארץ
נהדרת זה
כל השנים
לספר קצת על איזה חינוך אתה מקבל? מאיפה גן בית ספר
זה
לפני הגן המדף ללא
עברנו
ובית 'לוריאל
גן.
התחלתי
את הקריירה בשמו על ברחוב,
וזה עד סוף
עדיין רחוק.
אבל
כבר אין.
כן,
אז היה בשכונה גן
אחרי זה גם בית ספר עממי
בית הספר הלאומי.
והיה גם קצת תיכון, אבל אני כבר לא
אני כבר הייתי
דברים אחרים. כן,
אתה
הולך ל תנועת נוער.
אין לזה הסבר.
חוץ מדבר של היופי.
אני הילד היחידי אני חושב בשעות בעוף שירה בתנועה,
היא הייתה נחשף פעם ראשונה לענייני הגנה.
אתה
לא
אתה גדלת את זה. גדלתי עם זה, ואני לא יכול לשים
את קרב.
ומי שהייתי, הוא היה נוסע ברחבי הארץ
הרצל. התפקיד שלו היה ארצי.
נטיית
כל פרדס טוב, אוהב
בארץ
בעצם, בתקופה ההיא
זה מהים
זה
אומר שלי אחרי זה אז כך שהייתי נוסע איתו
בלי סוף אני לא יכול להגיד התחלתי
ליווית אותו
כן,
וזה עניין אותך זאת אומרת אסטלה בחיבה כי זה יסדה את עם זה מאוד כמובן,
היא גם שונה. בורוכוב, זה היה משהו מיוחד במינו
אז זה
היו שם הורים ידועים מאוד אבל זה
לא זה עכשיו
ואתה
אל מ
למה לא תחזור?
לא, אני אומר
יצחק שבגר ו
ואבא של עמיקם גורביץ'
הם היו מורים כאלה
ההורים שלי היו תלמידים של ברנר,
ביונסה, הרצליה
זה היה
לא
ו
זה מיוחד. היה
היא גם כל התלמידים בפרט ברחוב
היו
חברים בנוער
חוץ בנעימות.
כן,
אבל לא, זה לא היה מופגן ולא איזה אני לא
אחזיר. קרה שהיתה לו עם כל החברה
הייתה ההוצאה. העדר מדרך התחילה בתור ילד?
לא,
בכלל לא.
אז זה שבכלל לא, לכן הולכים למסע כל אחר הולכים לא הייתי הייתי מאוד משתתף ומסעות בזה
ואחר כך היה בגיל מאוד מוקדם נפגשתי לפלמ ח.
אני הייתי בפלמ ח
עוד לפני שהוא קם
במתכונת הידוע.
בהתחלה
אנחנו נפגשנו
סעיף
בעצמו
וישנה או השנתיים הראשונות
היה שפעם פעם ראשונה היו לוקחים אותו לתקופת אימונים.
כל אחד הפלמ ח כבר נהפך למחנות וכולו אז הייתי מהמחנות
ראשונים שלושת הפלוגות הראשונות
עד אחרי מלחמה. אני מרחמת, יושב
עברה
אני לא שואל אותך להורות
כי אתה לא יהיה לטפל אבל ב
אתה יודע הבאת להבין?
כן, היית שומעת
פה ועל חומה ומגדל ופה
בוא תספר איך הדברים
מצטיינים בעיניים של נער צעיר
הם לא עשו לנו שום גדול כי לא ידעתי שום דבר אחר אומר את זה הרבה
אה?
גם
בן דוד אחד
משהו היה בין מקימי
תל עמל
ו
ולמעשה כל הזמן אני לא יכול להגיד לו זמן
שלא היה
אתה יודע וזה ופה
אתה
הבאת לאביך, אגב,
לעליות על הקרקע של יישובים
אני זוכרת כל העליות
אבל אני לא הולך הרבה איזה? השתתפתי בזה לא בכחול הוא היה לוקח אותי
לעלי על חניטה אני זוכר כי כל הארץ הנדל ן בגלל
אבל היום
משמעות
האם מהישוב הדתי באמת ביצ'אם
טירת צבי
כן
תראה עצמי
אני העלתי הצבי היה משהו אבל היה עוד הרבה
אז אתה היית מגיעה עם אביך אגב ליום העלייה עצמו כן, כן, כן לא, זה רגוע
כן
ואז
ואמרו מהם את הנפש כמו שהוא אמר
כן
זכורים לך איזה אירועים
מיוחדים חריגים שהיו?
תשמע,
אם אני אספר על כל פעם שיעבוד היינו עושים בדרכים בלי סוף
ואני צריכים להגיע למשל לגלזגו טכנית, זה לא היה דבר פשוט.
זה חזית ערבית?
אשכרה.
אז אני זוכר אותם.
אני לך אותם. טוב מאוד.
זה היה גם די מפחיד לפעמים, ביחוד בגיל הרך,
נגע להתחיל לספוג
לפעמים כאלה זה מפחיד, אבל
מתי ירו עליכם?
כל
פעם
כל פעם.
מה? הייתי נוסע או עם אבא שלי? או עם דוד שלי?
כן.
יו ר.
לא, הם
לא אגם כאובה.
שם יש לי תירוץ.
והדרך ש זה
כשרציתי.
כן.
אז
אתה אומר שבאופן טבעי
להתגייס הפלמ ח בגיל צעיר זה היה אחרת. כן. אני אז למדתי בבית ספר המחוזי וגברת שלושה
מהתיכון של
המשך של
מוסדות החינוך של תנועת העבודה.
ו
זאת אומרת, זה היה די עצוב. קשה לי
להגיד מי תאריך. זה
בסדר. את
יודעת אם
כן
הייתה לך משיכה לים כבר ב נמצאים. כן,
זה כן
זה. כששאלו איך אתה משפחה חקלאית, אתה תותח.
לא נכון.
בגיל צעיר מאוד הייתי תולעת ספרים
וקראתי את כל הספרים שתורגמו
באותה תקופה לעברית.
כן,
והיה לי ברור
שאומרת לו לא אמרתי איך
לא
שאני
מה היא
כמו כל הנוסעים קפטן קוק וכל
ו
והגיל מצא התחלתי לעבוד עם דייגים, ואם זה ואין פה ושם
ו לפלמ ח
התגייסתי כשהייתי
בשביתה
בשביל אישה. תבעה אותך? הייתי ב
במסגרת הזאת של הפלמ ח
לפני שהיא הייתה במסגרת זה הזה
של הכשרות
לפני השקת את
הכסף. לפני הרבה לפני. עכשיו,
אבא שלי היה גם
בין שלושת האנשים
שקיבלו את ההחלטה.
זה האלוף אליהו בן חורג
אליהו כהן. אז
היה אחד שאחר כך הוא
האקו היה קומוניסט,
אבל הוא היה יחד עם אבא שלי. תיכף נגיע לזה.
לא כשר,
אבל
לא כאשר שרק ירד חזר לרוסיה,
נכון?
נכון. היו שמועות שהוא נהרג במלחמת ספרד.
הוא באמת
נלחם במלחמת ספרד.
גם אבא שלי
התנדב למלחמת שלו, לא?
כן,
אבל
אבא שלי אני
התנדב. אבל אמרו שהוא בגיל שכבר לא
מחיה מאלו שדגלו בהתנדבות למטא מטר מידע
כל מי ש מחבריו
שקיבלו אותו שלא היה מבוגר מדי.
כן.
ו
לגרמניה.
זה סוג שלושה אנשים
שהשומר שלך אותם אירגון השומר
הבא שנפגש. כפי שאמרתי, את אנשי השומר.
הוא היה שומר. הוא היה בחוץ למהומות.
אבל
נפסקו
מקומות המחיה.
אז הוא הוא
עבד כשומר.
והיא תראה אותי אנשי השומר
להצטרף לשומר
תצליח, שהוא הכיר את כל אשר שומר
אבל לא היה צעיר
ו
מי זה היה?
לא?
אז הליכה
הים,
אפשר לומר בגלל
הרצון שלו להתנדב בספרד, שהוא היה באגף היותר שמאלי שלך. לגמרי.
לגמרי.
העניין היה
באמת, כפי שאמרתי, שהוא היה מבוגר מדי,
אבל גם בשומר.
וגם בגדוד העבודה. וזה היה
גדוד העבודה. חלק ש
אין
לנו ממש מה
הג'ינג'י אומן הזה
הקומוניסט כסף, אבל
כן,
זה היה לו קשה.
לא
יחד עם לא קצרת זה שחזר.
זה שינהיג את ההחזרה.
כן. אני תכף מיזכר. כן, תהי. וגם אני,
אבל
לא קשה.
השומר שרך שלושה אנשים
במגמה אחרת.
ש
עם מבט קצת קדימה,
שיום יבוא וימצא להגיד
תשובה, תהיה מדינה.
אבל
מתי יישלחו לגרמניה?
זה עדיין למעלה,
אם את העולם הראשונה.
כן.
זה האזיק, לא כשר. ובכ בקיימן.
ויכול
ב כמו שלושה.
באיזה ניב
גם מחוץ ל
הם למדו
את זה.
אין משהו.
והיו רשומים לבית ספר צבאי בגרמניה,
אבל
לא קיבלו. זאת אומרת, הם לא יכלו להיות כי אם לא אזרחים גרמנים,
אז הם
השתתפו.
תודה.
ואז
אבא שלי, הוא היה מוכשר מאוד
בגיל. אני ראיתי
הסיורים שלו בגימנסיה הרצליה.
בית ספר עממי. זה קשה להאמין.
חלק מפה. אתה רואה
ילד,
אתה יכול לראות בקלות, יודעת, מאוד
מנסה. זה צילום מזווית
מן
מגדוד העבודה.
אז אתה רואה שזה אנשים
כשראו קרן שמש
וזהו. אז
הוא
נרשם
לאקדמיה על
ציור.
ולמד
את זה.
זה
אומר ש
אבל האקדמיה לציבור.
אולם את סיום, לא כמקצוע שהוא רצה. זאת אומרת, זה היה מין
גם וזרע הזהב אשר
גם וגם.
הוא
מגיל צעיר מאוד
באמת מגיל צעיר נראתי
שיעורים. קשה להאמין שזה
של ילד, אבל
אין לזה.
אסיע סגנונה
הגרמני
השאלה.
אוקיי,
אנחנו
בתקופת כרגע
על מדברים על תקופת מלחמת העולם השנייה בעולם יש מלחמה
אתה
לומד עד כיתה
עד הכיתה השביעית על ראשות בית ספר?
כן,
גבעת השלושה
ואז אתה מתייחס הפלמ ח כית איך היה התהליך עליך
לפי חשבוני אנחנו ב
בדיוק
זה אחרי כבר שם
הכל מר להתגבש ב
במאי.
אבל עוד לא היו מחנות עוד לא היה
זה כשאני
עכשיו ספר לי על התהליך
של הגיוס. אתה מתייצב.
פרט לקבוצה. לא
אחד מבאי ביתנו הקבועים שאני מאוד אהבתי ככה
היה בחור. זהו יופיעו ימי ש
שראה אותו לא ישכח אותו.
הוא היה באמת ימכרו
הקרובות
אף אחד
לא אמר לי. ככה
תשמע
על
זה.
למה את לא? כמובן.
אז הוא דיבר עם אבא שלי.
הוא שאמר
לו יכולתי
עכשיו מה שהוא רוצה
שנעשה
ואז,
אוי גייס אותי
לחצי שנה. הראשונה
של הפלמ ח
קים
אבל עוד לא היה במחנות.
וברגע שהקים אותם חיות
בסוף הבאים
בערך
עברתי
אז כשהוא גייס אותך לתקופה הראשונה. אז איפה הייתם ומה היתה משמעותית? אני משכתי.
רעיל מאוד. כן,
אבל מפעם לפעם.
כן,
כן, כן, כן.
אז המשכת ללמוד.
ומתי אתה מחליט שאתה
כשהקימו את המחנות אתה. ברגע שהכירו את המוכנות
הצטרפתי. וזה איפה המחנה של הפלוגה
הוא
יגור גבת ו
באיחור.
אז
אתם עברתם שם אימונים רציניים. התחלתם לעבור מאוד מאוד
באותה תקופה עוד היה שיתוף פעולה עם הצבא הבריטי
והאם פירושו נוראים. אימון מעולה. אירו
היה לכם אחרי אוהלים
סכן בוץ? כן.
בהתחלה
המשכנו באורח החיים הרגיל.
והיום הרכזים אותנו שבוע שבועיים ממונים
אחת לחברנו למחנות
האימונים הועברו על ידי סגל
ברובו
בהתחלה
מה זה הקורס ל צלפות
אבל לאט לאט
התחילו
הטיפוסים זהו יופיעו
ברנר
כל אלה משונה הפלמ ח
שהיו בה נוטות ובכל
כן
כמה זמן אתה הייתם מחלקה ביאהו ב כן,
כן. כמה בערך הייתם כאן?
חמישים.
חמישים?
רק
רק בנים.
אז
מוניקה,
ככל שהולך הזמן, ככל שחולף הוא חולף הזמן והזקנה בארץ
פוחתת
אז משתנה היחס של
מאחור קופי השירות. ואני זוכר בדיוק שפתאום הודיע לנו
מי עכשיו
היה
שם את עינו
גם מקפידים מאוד
ללבוש בגדים אזרחיים.
בפלמ ח היה
היו מדהימים.
ואם
את זה כל זה שקובע נהיינו מחתרת.
אז פתאום הבריטים כבר מפסיקים להיות
כן כבר את איפה את צריך להתנהל?
היה לכם נשק מוחזר לויתי משהו, רני, שזה
זה הנשק שלנו.
אז
ברגע שמשתנה אופי השירות שלכם מה באתם הופך הופכים להיות מחתרת
מה? מבחינה פרקטית
אין את פרטי קורא לכם אתם
אתם הופכים להיות מתי אתם הופכים להיות הכשרה של
עובדת? ואני לא דיברנו לא הייתה בהכשרה המגוייסת אז הוא לא
אבל
מוכרחים להגיד
איזה סיפור תיכף אספר לך
ש
הרעיון
זהו הקיבוץ המאוחד
הקיבוץ הם
חשבו מה לעשות אתה לא יכול להחזיק מחנה צבאי
אז התחילו לעשות
היה נוק מחנה אוהלים
באיחור
חרך בגב' בעוד הרבה
ממקום למקום
ו
הוא היה נראה כמו כאן יש לחשוב
וכל ההתנהלות את האל כשל
אבל גם
כמחנה צבאי לכל דבר
אפילו מסדר בוקר
ש בפלמ ח אחר כך לא היו
הירח
וזה הרעיון מוכרחים להגיד
ש
לימים אני אקח את חוק סיפור
פעם
היו חברים?
כן
לא לך? בדיוק. איפה הייתי אז
הכרתם מישהו? היו היו סינים
ו
ראיתי
כשהסינים האלה
הם יודעים עלינו הכל
אני לא רואה
זה
אחר כך פגשתי פעם את
אחד מהאנשים המרכזיים שלהם
אז הוא אמר לי
וזה אני מתפלא שלא בא לי
להתייחס שפרסמתי את זה המון
על המון פניות מההיסטוריונים מצוין
הרב
קצת
הסינים ידעו את זה
והם אמרו לי זה עניין אותי מאוד
הוא התחיל לדבר אתי ודיברנו ודיברנו ואז
הוא יודע הכל זה לא יתואר
עכשיו שהוא הגיב על זה
אז
מסתבר שהם
ידעו את הדבר הזה
והם אמרו זה היה המודל לחיקוי שלנו.
ייתכן. אמרתי לו ככה
ב ענווה האמיתית לא זה
איפה אנחנו ואיפה אתם
אמרה הכי גדולה ואומה החיצונה.
אז הוא אומר דבר אחד משותף
כולנו התחלנו מאפס
ו אפס זה אפס
מאוד מצא חן בעיניי.
והם ידעו והם הקימו בהתחלה,
לפני שקארמה הרפובליקה הסינית
שאנחנו מכירים
והם הקימו
עותק של הפלמ ח
זה לא צחוק
מעשים הם עשו פה,
לא פה.
איפה
עכשיו? כן,
בחוץ לארץ.
אז
הם הקימו ולמדו היטב את
הכירו את הפלמ ח בית כל,
וגם את צורת ההתקשרות והחור
הכל.
אז בואו ניכנס רגע להיכנס למסגרת של לוח זמנים
את
משהו
ב
אתה מתגייס לפלמ ח
פול טיים
בערך שנפתח הגיוס
פשוט נתנו לי
כן.
כמה זמן אתה נמצא ביד?
כמה זמן דרך
בגור נמצאת ולא
קשה רימון לתחום את זה
מפני ש
היו תקופות
למעשה
הפלמ ח
המסגרת אם מוכר של הפלמ ח.
זו היתה המצאה
של הקיבוץ המאוחד.
הם הציעו את זה, אמר,
אנחנו
המושקים שלנו. זה המקום שהם יחיו ויעבדו וכולו כולו.
ו
זה היה ב.
ואתה כבר לא הגעת למצב
לשלב בשלב הזה של
שהולכים ומצטרפים.
כן מחלקות
כי הכשרות מגויסות אותה.
אני לא הייתי בכשרון אבל הייתי כל התקופה עד סוף המלחמה הזאת, המלחמה היא דבר.
אבל מה
אתה יודע?
אז
תגיד לי
את האישה של
איפה ואיפה אתה היית,
רק בקיבוץ יגור?
לא. זאת אומרת,
אני לא זוכרת את כל הממשקים. לא, כל פעם היו מעבירים עונה,
לפעמים היה צריך לעשות זה זיקוק
לדוגמה.
וזה? הקורס היה די. זה קיבוץ
כמו הכשרה, אבל זה היה המסמר.
איזה קורסים את הספקת לעבור?
זה היה
חבלה.
עוד כל מיני דברים מקצועיים מהסוג
כן.
עדיין שום דבר בעניין אנרגיה מאוד
לא.
אבל
בשלב מסוים, יותר מאוחר,
העניין של עלייה ב
קיבל את המקום שהוא ידוע.
זאת אומרת, למעשה, הפלמ ח
הפעילות
המרכזית
הייתה
עלייה ב.
ואז
ביקשתי לעבור.
אז הוא יופי שהיה מפקד הפלוגה שלנו
לא הסכים וקולו. ופה ושם
התווכחנו והתווכחנו. בסוף עברתי
הפלוגה הימית
קיסריה,
בעוד יום
להיות יום
ו.
אני
אז איזה איזה עכשיו אתה עובר שם?
די
מחשבה טובה מאוד. דווקא
לימים, כשהייתי כבר חובל ו
שאל אותי הרבה פעמים,
אמרתי הרים הרבה הפתעה.
אני לא יודע מה בשטחים אחרים
בשטח הזה. היתה לנו קשורה
מאוד יסודי
מפעם לפעם
כשאפשר היו מהלימון אותנו על אוניה.
לעבוד פשוט על אונייה
זה
למדנו את זה טוב,
אבל גם לבן הוא
קורס חובלים
ששמענו גם את כל הלימודים האקדמיים, מה
כמו שעכשיו
וכמובן
מפקדי סירות וכל מפקדי נסיעות. ואף על פי
כן עוד לפרט קצת
את התכנית של הקורס. פחות.
זה התחיל
בקורס מפקדי סירות.
כל משהו
לעמוד
של כלי שייט קטנים.
אני.
אבל האג ח. גם
מפעם לפעם
שנותנים לנו שירות לא נהיה ממש.
וככה זה היה.
אני גם
אני שאלתי לא פעם.
היות ולאחר מכן
הייתי
זה
מה שהייתי
בספנות הישראלית,
וגם הייתי ראש
הארגון,
הגוף הבוחן וכולי וכל. הוא שאל אותי מה דעתי
מבחינה מקצועית,
כי הם הסביבתי, כמי שכבר היה
רב חובל כולו.
אז אמרתי המפתיעה של הלימון שלנו היה
מצוין.
בסדר.
הקורס הראשון של מפקדי סיבות
או לא
הייתי בקורס הרביעי, אני חושב.
וואו, ביום חמישי
מתי יהיה אתה מפליק פעם ראשונה לחו ל
במסגרת הקוף במסגרת העלויות, אבל לא
עד
כדי כך
להפלגות באוניות.
הצלחתי קולמן שזה יסתדר,
תובל
אחר כך שכבר זה היה בידינו.
אז היינו דואגים לכך
שכל מי שעבר כראש חובלים
וקורס יותר מתקדם, שגם
יצריך
ניכר כחצי שנה.
אז
אחרי, אנו
משלבים
הפתיחות לקפריסין. לא, לא באונייה
אונייה באוניה, וגם באמת
נשאלתי
כשהייתי ראש
צוות הבוחנים
והם מצמיחים.
אז שאל אותי, במבט לאחור,
איך היו הלימודים
בכל?
אמרתי שלמרבה ההפתעה לימודים
טובים מאוד.
אין לו
כמו שמוליק טנק, רוץ בראשית
וכל החבר'ה האלה
גם מבוגרים מאיתנו.
והיו זה היה הכל לפי
סילבוס ולפי זה של
מדינות הים.
כן!
וכל
כמה זמן נמשך הקוף
בקיסריה בשדות כחצי שנה.
אז
כן,
מתחילה
אל הים
לתפוס תאוצה. הספינה הראשונה
שנתפסה על ידי הבריטים
זה הבר לקצה נלסון.
זה היה כבוד להיתפס אליה
ולשבט
חצי שעה שונה
בין הטובות.
בוא תספר. אחד
הופך להיות
שים סיר.
אז
איך אתם איך מתחיל איך מתחילה
התפלה
שלך מבחינתך
אתה יוצא לחו ל. אבל זה
קודם. לפני זה
התכוננו לקבלת בערך עצמך פרסום.
ואז כבר היה חשש
שהבריטים יעצרו אותם.
ואכן כך היה.
הבר כצנלסון הגיע לחוף שפיים.
הספקנו להוריד
את כל המפעילים.
חוץ מהסירה האחרונה
הוא כשל
איתן. כבר
אין לנו כבר ריסוס
עם לצאת או לא, כי ראינו
שהבריטים מרכזים סירות
ואוניות לא הפחיד אותם. הם לא יכולות להתקרב כל כך,
אבל עשירון
כן.
חברות
זה
אמרת אוניות לא יטרידו אתכם בגלל
כן, הם לא יכולות להתקרב כל כך.
אבל ראינו סירות
וכבר
חשבנו לצאת.
תוכלו לתפוס לנו וזה
חושף
מעיינות סיירה.
יצאנו. ואז
על יד האונייה
תפסו אותנו.
אבי עבד אל לתקופת החקירות.
זו התקופה הכי לא נעימה.
ויפו בירושלים. איך כולכם,
מילה הסתירה
היא להסתיר, אבל
חוקרים
כן.
ספר כצנלסון
בארבר כץ ברצוני
קבורה
הלכתי ב
ב
בדרך כלל היה
אנשי האונייה.
אחר כך הקבוצה שמקבלת
באחר
את חוזרת טינה?
כן,
כן.
בבידוד.
היתה קבוצה שהוא מקבל
ואחר כך אוקיי שלוקחים מפזרים אותם
בפרדסים במישחקים בכל
במקומות האלה,
מסתבר, לחץ לפרסום
התקווה.
זו הספינה הקטנה.
כן.
אוראנו במהירות האפשרית את כל זה
נשארה בערך סירה.
וכבר ראינו
כי פיתה עם המשחתות. היה להם
פרויקטים חזקים מאוד.
וכמו שאנחנו עומדים בזהירות
ואחריו, שאנחנו כמו באור יום,
אה,
המשחתות עמדו מסביב
שלוש ארבע
ומועיל. סירות,
סירות מנוע
ואין לנו. כפי שאמרתי,
קצת היסוסים להסתלק או
היה ברור לי משום מה הם באו
כסף. החלטנו התחלנו נגמור עד הסוף.
בנו
העלנו
את
הסירה האחרונה
ויצאנו לחזור לרחוב.
הם הקיפו אותנו
חיוביות.
זה יהפוך אך ירושלים זה התקופת
חקירות
כמה נעצרו בסירה
חוץ מ העולים הבלתי לגאליים. כמה
מאחל בשבילך
אנחנו היינו שני מסר
כי אני זוכר
היו קוראים לנו על שני מסעות.
אז
היינו שתי סירות
שלמה.
שתי סירות.
אני אומר הייתה תקופה זה רק להביא אותן לתרום.
באותה תקופה
היה קצת
זה
מצב עדין
מפני שהאויר לטלתרום
ו בלטרון
ישבו באותה תקופה
אנשי העצב והליכי
אנשי שלומנו
תפסו אותם בשטח.
זה זו
לא, ונהנה.
בסדר, אז זו
תודה רבה.
אז בתקופת הסזון.
היו ביניכם קשרים?
או עכשיו זה סיפור מעניין.
וגם יש ממנו מוסר. ההשכל
כשבאנו לנתון,
היה חשש רציני לחייו
במוסדות שלנו.
כמו שאי אפשר לדעת
מה יחליטו לעשות
אלה פה
איש
שם יש
לא טוב,
אז
קבעו פגישה. זה אני יודע.
מאחר כך
קבעו פגישה עם המפקדים של עצם דרך
ואמרו להם בשפה מאוד מאוד
נדיר בלקום
שערה אחת
מהחברה שלנו.
אבל לא היה שום צורך
מפני.
הם באמת לא ידעו מה לעשות ובעצם לא היינו קבוצה
אבל לא יצאו השבוע. שבועיים שמע, מעצר עושה את שלו
ואנחנו היינו חלק
מ
חלק גם לא מבוטל.
זה
זהו.
עכשיו הוא
הוא קשרים בין חיים.
בטח. מה זה? שנים אחרי זה
הייתי נפגש עימה
אם האנשים האלה היו ביניהם כאלה שכאשר מדידות
והוא לא
ו
זה היה ברור שברגע שאתה יושב מעצר
אז אין יותר דברים כאלה
אתם ישבתם והם למעשה במעצר מינהלי?
כן, לפי התקנות שאתחיל אום
כן.
מתי? בסופו של דבר אתה משוחרר
את זה?
שוחררנו
בערך
שנה
לא היה איזה מעורב מיוחד, אבל,
כלומר,
אחרי תנועת המרי
אחרי אשתו, בועת אוויר,
זאת אומרת, אחרי מלון המלך דוד?
בערך,
בערך אחרי מה לומר לך
בואו לספר קצת על חיי יום יום בלטרון.
אני יודע שזה יצחיק אתכם, אבל זו האמת.
עלי הייתה כל השנים. היום זה כבר
נבחרה. עבר
סליחה, זיכרון טוב מאוד.
תיאטרון. עשינו חיים.
זאת אומרת,
כל חיינו
תמיד עבדנו ועבדנו קשריי,
כי גם אבא נו, וגם התאמנו, וגם זה. וגם זה. וגם
לא פתאום
צריך.
הבעיות של הצעירים זה להעביר את הזמן
יותר
טוב. שתשמע אנחנו השתלבנו בנבחרת טק מטורף ונצטרך את
הכדורסל. והיינו שם עשינו חיים, כמו שאומרים,
אני
אפילו האוכל. הוא לא היה אוכל ש
היינו מקבלים מהבריטים. אז יש תקנות כך וכך הגשרים ליום
הלילה,
אבל גם קיבלנו בלי סוף מכל מוסדות ומכל מי זה?
עשינו חיים
אז
בזכרון שלי עשינו חיים,
ואחר כך
שחררו אותנו
כמעט,
כי
אנחנו נורא יתקומם
לעבוד.
כן, אנחנו במשך חצי שנה הכנו בריחה,
אבל כנראה שהיו גם אצלנו
לא שוויצרי אחד,
או מה אנחנו
ואנחנו
נברח כמו האלה שחצי שעה חבורה
חפרו מנהרה.
אנחנו לפרוץ בכוח.
אז עבר נשק.
מה זה? והוא מצפה אלייך.
איך זה הגיע עד אליהם?
לא יודע,
אבל הוא הגיע אלינו.
זאת אומרת, כל פעם שהיה ביקור, מישהו היה מבין.
ועל היום דארן בנט
ויודע שאפילו
כי זו הודעה אחת,
יום אחד
מפחדים שלה. היא
עצם ולכי ביקשו מאתנו פגישה.
אין לו כמה אנשים ש
למרות לשמור.
אתמול
שלשום
הגיע למחנה
מישהו
כשיש לו פסק דין מוות
אלה. הם רק לא יודעים שזה
תוך ימים. יומיים. זה התברר.
אנחנו בטוחים שיש לכם?
אל תגיד לא. לא
בטוחים שיש שם.
אנחנו עושים כשיש
לו נשק
לבריחה.
אמר
שהוא מקבל זה אשוק ואנחנו אנשים פרטיים.
קיבלנו אישור
תקף. ללא קול,
לא
כל איסוף.
ניתן לו נשק
עבורכן בך.
בסדר.
אני לא זוכר את השם שלך.
הוא גם לא היה בשם שלו.
זה סיפור לא רע.
הוא צריך לברוח עם נשק. מה? הוא יהיה בריא. שוטר. איפה לא יהיה
בה
לעבור את
הגדרות. זו הייתה בעיה.
הוא מחביא אותו
הזו
ברח בסתר.
אבל הוא היה צריך להיות מוכן
שאם
יגלו אותו
השר
ואז שוב היה לו נשק
שנים אחרי זה. פעם אחת
פגשתי מישהו אמר לי שזהו היה,
אבל לא,
לא הכרתי.
ו
ולכן כשאנחנו
איחרנו,
אמרנו, אנחנו לא נתחיל.
היו כמה אנשים
מהלכי, אני חושב.
חצי שנה הם חפרו
לפניכם. או
עוד לפני בזמן שאמך בזמן שכן
טוב.
כן, אתה בריחה נוספת. כן.
אז אמרנו, אנחנו לא
נתחיל עם כל הזה.
אנחנו נפרוץ,
אז הביאו לנו נשק.
ועוד אנחנו
מתכננים
אמרו לנו תרצו,
לא עושים כלום. אז
אתם עושים מאיתנו צחוק.
בקיצור יצאנו.
השארתם את הנשק לעבר שנשארו? כן.
למה
לא מוצא עם נפש להיקבר במקום כזה,
וזהו.
אז היית שם שנה?
באיזה בית הבראה
אתה קורא מבחינתי
בתפקוד?
אני זוכר תקופה בה גם בבית לנו בבית המשק, וזה
היה רק הייתי בא מבית ספר מזה. הייתי עובד כמו חמור
פה פתאום.
כן.
יש גם
דברים כאלה בעולם.
אז
אפרופו, לא דיברנו על זה שבאמת חזרת בנשק המשפחה במשק בית?
כן, תשעה משנה. מה היה סדר היום שלך? בסדר. לא הייתי הולך לבית ספר,
אבל שהייתי חוזר
לא מזמן
במקרה
נפגשנו עם הבני דודים ודודות שלי.
מה שהם זוכרים זה
לימוד תמיד עבד כמו חמור במשק.
זה נכון. אחרי בית הספר, הייתי בא הביתה, הייתי עובד במשק,
אבא שלי היה מאוד מאוד עסוק.
אבל עברנו יחד זה
אז
אם זו
איזה היה לכם פרות? היו לכם הכול? הקונה היה,
למשל,
פרות. תרופות. זה
אין לנו משק די יפה.
זה הייתה
הכנסה
הכרחית, בייחוד לתקופות שאבא שלהם שגויה. אז
צריך קצת
בשוק הזה.
אני היה עושה. היא תחלים עד הבוקר.
מ ש
י מ.
לא היינו קיימים. הוא מאוד מוקדם.
הייתה לי סבתא.
הנה.
זו היתה האישה
מימין. זה אמא שלי.
זה לא,
לא, לא, לא. לא אצלם אחר כך. לא, זה
אי אפשר
קופצים לזה.
בסדר?
באופק כרגע לספר על כל אחד מהם קודם על השמאלית.
רק עכשיו הזכיר את
זאת אמא של אליהו
ושל אמא שלי
שהיא מינה
ו
היא הייתה קשה
ממש.
אני זוכר שהייתי הולך איתה כשאנחנו ברגל לתל אביב. זה
קצרים. גם את אנשי הליכוד, העבודה כבר
את ההזדמנות שלך. כן, זה נכון.
זה נכון.
כן.
אז מה צריך
אמרת
כשהיית שם? מה
היא הייתה חולבת בזה וזה,
אבל כששדה דל טכני, שנה שנתיים ראיתי, עובד איתה.
לא,
לא
תודה.
תעלו ל טרפת את הפרדס
לעוף.
כמה? כמה
מה היה שלך? שניים וחצי דונם למתיישבי.
אז זה כבר אפשר
כזה כבר מאפשר.
טוב,
אגיד לפני שאנחנו
ממשיכים בכרונולוגיה לתקופה של שוחרר תלמיד בסוף
אני מעריך משהו מהשוק כזה עם מחצית שנייה שבה
יש לך משהו חשוב ברצף של עד עכשיו שדיברנו לספר עליו, וזה
כי זאת דוד דברים שלא
הסכמת באסוציאציה.
תראה, זה היה מאוד מאוד מעורבב. נאומיו אצלי,
כי כילד נסעתי הרבה מאוד עם אבא שלי, גם אם אליהו, גם
אם
פחות
שוק,
כבוד
ו
אבא שלי עשה גם בזה וגם בחקלאות
ואני אותו דבר. אבל כילד הזה כמובן קצת אחרת.
אתה זוכר שדודתך
ניסתה בית
אחרים?
אה, זה עולם
של משפחת מאד.
כן,
לספר על זה היום
נורא.
אני למדתי אם אתה מקים הבת שלהם,
אבל הכרתי את האחות שלה ואת
זה ואת
זה
עדה תמיר ואת כל
אלה שנהרגו זה היה פשוט משהו ש
סליחה,
אסון משפחתי נורא
אבל
אין הוא אומר ומספר פשוט מישהו סיפר
אנחנו כל הביתה היה המום
פתאום עלה בעיר
בגרות
פחמן
חיה או משהו
ככה משפחה שלמה
טוב, אז אתה
משתחרר ממחנה המעצר בלטרון ומה קורה איתך בהמשך
אני חוזר לפלמ ח
ו
ממשיך בקורסים כפריים אחר
בגוש במרין
בקורס עמים
רבים זוהר
מספר קצת
רוזי קורס מאוד ידוע שומר משהו
תספר איך אתה עובר
במה
יהיה זה אה, זה קשה
הנה
פה לא עשינו חיים
זה
זה קורס
למעשה זה הקורסים הראשונים
של צה ל כי זה היה תקופת המעבר
האימונים היו ממש אימונים קשים
בהתחלה עוד היו כמה מדריכים
בריטיים
לנש ק סוגי נשק
זה שם
אחרי שאתה משתחרר
לטרון עדיין היה כאשר עם מדריכים בריטיים
יש פה איזה
יכול להיות
כמו מה
הרבה
יכול להיות שאת הקורס מקים עשית
הו כשהעיתון ידאגו לפני המעצר שלך עוד לפני הפנייה
לא,
חכו, זה מבוכה את המהממים עשיתי
בדויה
אתם הם כבאים עשיתי ביטוח
גם אם הם היו בינתיים
ביניהם
אז
ציינת שאנו פה בריטי ואני
רואה קצת
לא ברור מממן אותו
בימים ההם הם בטח לא כל כך עם אופציה
עוקבים. אני חושב שזה התקופת.
כבר לא. היה לנו אימונים גלויים עם מדריכים בריטים,
אבל הם לא רדפו אותנו באופן.
אז היה הקורס מקיפים שעשית בתשובה? כן.
מי? המפקד הכוז?
יצחק רבין,
כמובן.
מי היו חברי? חלק הוא שהם הפכו להיות
סגורות.
כולם היו
נהפכו לפי גויות.
אבל
לא כולם נשארו.
אני, למשל, לא נשארתי. אני עברתי לפרוג הימית.
העברתי לעליה ב
ו.
בבקשה.
זהו זה
הדבר. את הקורס ומקיפים
בדבריו
כל הזמן
לא אוכל. אני זוכר
תקופה מסוימת. אמרתי
אזיקים. אותה פלוגה, האמת,
עלייה ב
תפס
מומנטום.
ואני, אה,
ביקשתי לחג. נדרש לי
אמרתי, אם לא אני,
אל תביא אותי ידי זה שאני אעזוב
עלה על אונייה,
אני רוצה לעבור הפלוגה הימית עבדים פוגע ימית
ואז יצאתי פעם ראשונה שאתה יודע על זה אתה
אז יצאתי פעם ראשונה, קצת לפני הקמת המדינה.
מפני שאני זוכר כש כשנסעתי לחוץ לארץ,
עוד
היינו במחתרת.
אבל כש
החוצה,
חזרתי כבר היתה
לא, זה היה טרום מדינה כזה
בתקופת הדמדומים
של המנדט הבריטי. כן, כן. לצאת בנובמבר
אחרי הכפתור.
בסדר.
כן.
עכשיו יצאת באוניה של צי הסוחר? לא,
נסעתי ב
ב תחת השם
דוד
ג'ו ינקובסקי.
זאת אומרת, היו הם פספורטים.
כן.
יש לנו קבוצה
שאחד מהם היה העיקר.
אז הכרת תודה ראשונה
אני
רוצה. יש חמישה. שישה
נסענו לפראג.
למה? בפראג.
וזה? פראג הייתה בגוש ניטרלי כזה.
לא היה על זה עוד לא ידוע על קשר ישיר
לעלייה בית וכולו מאסו סטודנטים על ידי.
אז יצרנו
אחד אצלנו
מתל אביב
לפג. שלושה ארבעה ימים.
יום אחד נסענו עד אתונה.
היו שני עד או עד
זו היתה עליהם
והגענו ל
כשאתה אומר נסענו ותעשו,
טסנו. כן,
אבל הזמנים
זה
עשה לו
מהארץ.
עד זה,
או אולי
זה
היה כך עוד ועוד ועוד דברים. שלושה ארבעה ימים עד שהגענו לפראג,
בפראג. היינו
זמן מסוים בכוונה
לטשטוש עקבות.
שם קיבלנו תלונות אחרות וכו' וכו לא?
והיינו בפראג
כחודש,
רק ככה ש
ואחר כך
אז
שלחו אותי לעלות על אנייה,
אומרת מהפעילים.
אז
מה זה?
כשיצאה
מצפון איתה,
מביאה רייטינג גבוה
מאיתנו,
מה היה שמה של הספינה?
אחרי כמה ממשיך לבעוט בשם של
בסוף
זכרתי. זה
בסוף היתה החלוץ, אני חושב.
סופיה,
אמרת שאיתך
בטיסה יעב
ץ
בהרבה
בקיץ, היה כל פרשת אקסודוס.
זה התקף אחרי
שוב.
זה
רגע ברכב.
הוא לא הספיק להיות כמעט בארץ.
מאוד קשה.
אז אתם
מה יהיה התפקיד שלך
ב ספינת המעפילים המלווה? זה הכל?
כן,
כך
אתה יכול לספר על שאל שאלות של הארגון של העלייה וכל הדברים
הארגון. אני לא הייתי לא עסקתי בזה אז אני לא כל כך יודע
הספינה שאתה היית מיועד הריאליטי.
עליתי עליה קצת קודם
ככה
לא היית שותף לעבודות הקאה
עכשיו? אני לא היו כאלה שכן
אתה לא?
לא, אני לא.
רגע כמה היום קודם יותר
תוך שבוע שבועיים קודם
הבנייה כבר הוכנה ונסעה
אני זוכר ש
לראשונה
יצאנו מביה רג'י
ונפגשנו עם ספינה
או
הספינה היה שמע החלוץ
שעבר אלינו
בלב ים
העברנו את את כל הזה
היתה אופרציה
רוצים את זה לא צחוק להעביר
איך עושים את זה?
חכה רגע. היה מזג אוויר טוב?
כן,
נכנסנו.
יש למפרץ עמוק
בצפון סרדיניה
גולף או ג'יי ג'יי חולה אתה
ושם עמדנו אחד על השני
למה
אצלנו
זה
סאנו והפלא עלינו לארץ בדרך לארץ
התחילו ללוות אותנו
משחתות כבר
בחצי הדרך.
ואחרי שעברנו את הנושאים והתחלנו
להפליא לארץ
הבריטים תפסו אותם.
אבל נתפס פעם שנייה.
כן.
מי היה רב החובל שלו? איטלקית
הוא ידע
מאז פאוולוב אלה חלק, חבר. ממש
מבריחים מוליכים. כן,
בטח
היה מהעולם התחתון של האיטלקים.
כמה מהפעילים היו
בסביבות שבע
אבל בחוץ. והעברה של המעפילים לאונייה, לאונייה
לא עד שתפסו אותנו.
איזה ערך בשאגה
ב
הופיע משך את
אחת. אחר כך שנייה,
ידענו שכבר
אבל
יש
שעלו על עקבותינו.
זאת אומרת שהבריטים, למרות שכבר עם רגל אחת בחוץ
עדיין מונעים, אני יכ מה שהייתי אומר המון פעמים
כשהיו מדברים הבריטים הבריטי עומד לחבריהם.
תודה.
איך אני? הרי אנחנו עובדי תעמולה. מה? אתם מבלבלים את המוח?
הייתם צריכים, היינו צריכים
להיתפס לזה. הצרפתים או האמריקאים?
אז היינו חוטפים,
אנג למה
לא, אני שואל הפוליטיים, למרות שהם כבר יודעים ש ב
במאי
נגמר המנדט.
הם ממשיכים במדיניות שלך, אמרת? כן, אדוני, עד הים האחרון
עד היום.
אז אתם נתפסים בלב ים ומועברים ישר לקפריסין.
כן,
הנוסעים
אותך בדרך כלל לא היו מחירים סליקים ב ספינת מעפילים כזו כדי להחליט הבעיות גם אצלנו היה.
אבל
כן, היינו
מאוחר.
זה
אנוכי.
ועוד מישהי אחות
סימה.
אני רואה.
כבר
היה גדעוני.
אתה יודע מי זה פה בכם?
שמו הוא בן הורן
והוא
כן. מאז אנחנו כאן.
הוא יגיד
אז
אמרת שהכנתם סליקים, אבל לא התחבאתם. לא, לא. כן. אני לא התחבר.
אני הוחלט
למה הסכמתי אבל הוחלט
שאני
צריך להמשיך עם המפעילים. אי אפשר לעזוב אותם.
אז
מהכבוד הזה נפל,
וחלקי ו
טוב,
רצית עוד תקופת נופש. כן, אני
יודע.
בכלל
לא.
כן.
אז אחרי שיסתדרו בסניף
חולצו משרה כן, כן, במקשה.
בלילה הראשון
באור החיוור אני סולל בונה ומישהו צילם
את זה.
אז מתי הייתה מגיעה לכאן בסיסיים פחות או יותר את זה כבר בתחילת.
אני חושב שכבר היתה מלחמה. אני לא בטוח.
אני לא
הולך
לא.
כמה זמן אתה בקפריסין?
בקפריסין הייתי כמו מה חודשים
בקפריסין גם הכנו בריחה.
חפרנו
מנהרה מתחת לגדר
אז זה זה
אפילו נכנסנו ויצאנו כמה פעמים
לראות
איך זה היה. עמוס תביעה פיתח
לפיס בהתאם לטפל
מי מהמחנה
עלייה לדר היה איזה קבוצת שיחים כזאת
יותר גבוהה
אז חפרנו עד שם
קודם יצאנו מדאנו אותו מרחב.
רק חפרנו בדיוק את שם יצאנו ואין שם.
ויצרנו לי שום בעיה
באמת?
איך הסתדרתם את הפתח בתוך המחנה?
את האדמה שהוצאנו
מהמנהרה
עשינו הרוג אותו.
בסדר.
ואת הפתח הרי הבריטים מסתובבים בערך.
מה היה בטח הזה מתוך אוהל
בתוכו ממשלה או הייתה המחסן?
זה פשוט.
אתם ניצלתם את הזמן כדי לאמן את המעפילים. את העולם לא יכול להביא
שמסלולו ארגון
מהצבא יכולים לעבור ללמוד
באמת?
אתה הדרכתה בעצמך? כן מיטב
מה?
כל לכל מקום שבדרגה מדרך לדום
לשם פיקודך הם באוכל וזה
כן
פחות אוכל.
אוקיי, אם אתה היית מגיע לארץ בקיץ
זה היה בקע אצל הבחור
בחורף אתה מגיע זה מאוחר.
מאוחר מדי למה?
כי
המדינה קרוב ל
במאי
למעשה נפתחו שערי קפריסין
אני חושב שאתה היית באלה המועדפים לצאת מהראשונים אבל לא הייתי בין הראשונות.
לא היית יודע את זה, אבל
אני לא יודע למה, אבל לא הייתי מת
בכלל, לא
כן,
אז אתה את כל
התקופה, נניח סתם, אני אומר
בוש, רמלה, לוד
הוא
עוד לא הייתי בעיה. לא, לא, לא, לא.
ויצאת דרך לנגב. עוד לא היתה בארץ. למשל, מבצע יואב
עם כיבוש באר שבע אתה שומע? זה שם תיכף אחרי כיבוש באר שבע
או
טקס אחרי, כי זו אז אנחנו מדברים על נובמבר.
אוקיי, גבוהה רחוב.
אז אתה מגיע לארץ ומה אתה עושה?
מתייצב.
איפה היה המטה של הפלמ ח
על שפת הים? שם? באיזה מקום
באתי לשם אמור להתחכם בבית
טוב יום יומיים
וצירפו אותי לחטיבת הנגב.
אתה מגיע לחטיבת הנגב
עוד לפני מבצע חורף,
יצטרכו זמן קצר לפני
הרצח. וזה תפקיד. אתה מקבל בו
פאר קצת.
היא
לא מי יודע מה,
הייתי באיזה מן המתנה כזאת,
אבל
אה,
צירפו אותי.
מצחיק,
היה לי רישיון נהיגה,
וזה היה
מה היא תחכה פה. יש
והקימו. אז יחידת הג'יפים
שלך אותי ואת
הצטרפת לכת אם כן,
תודה.
כן.
מה עשית במבצע חורף?
ניסיתי חיים, אז
אילן ואז נסעתי.
ואיפה היתה היחידה שלך? באר שבע.
אבל
יצאתם מבאר שבע. אתה כבר באר שבע כבר היתה כבושה לא,
אמר בשבע יותר כמו שהוא.
כן. אז יצאתם מבאר שבע למבצע חורף?
כן. כן, כבר מאז. אז
הכל זה צעד
צעד.
אז בואו תספר מה עשית
במסגרת הזו. אבל הייתי ב
מקרו היפו
ב
פלוגת הג'י ומושחת שבת הנג.
נתתם חיילים באיזה קרב?
כן או
כל דבר.
עכשיו ספר אותם ללא לקרבות. אין לי מה לספר מפני
שאני לא זוכר
הכל
בסדר אסוציאטיבית, בלי סדר חומר.
לא, לא. אני אומר
כל מה שהיה
אם אני ארצה לדעת בדיוק. אני אלך ל
לספר. אני יודע.
כן. מה אתה זוכר בכל זאת? מיד לעצמך?
הרבה החוצה
הייתם ביעוץ, יא ביימו, שריף
ומה השרפה? ועוד שעה בכל המקומות
האלה?
כן,
כן.
איך
תשמע מה אני זוכר? אני זוכר.
לא, זה
זה קרב מאוד מאוד ידוע
כי יהיו המון קרבות תנינים.
למעשה,
אנחנו אני
התחלתי והייתי עד סוף המלחמה
בסילוף הצבא המצרי
בדרום
ו
אם אני זוכר זוכר
איך אף אחד לא זוכר מה היה
שם?
רמז באמצע המדבר
יותר טרגי ל
מ ל? כן,
המלך
ואל את מל הקרב גדול
גדול בין
גם מבחינה מספרית.
אני זוכרת איזו הודעה
הייתה הוראה לפני ההסתערות האחרונה.
ככה היית
אנחנו. התקדמנו. התקדמנו.
הגענו לרגל
הרכב
ואז
אמרו שהוא עומד להיות קרב גדול כי כבר מרכזים בשני הצדדים
כוחות גדולים,
וההורה הייתה
לא לעצור
בשביל להגיש
עזרה לפצועים.
זה הדרג השני, אז
זה בסדר.
אתם המסתערים להמשיך
הופעת ההזדמנות,
ואז
אני זוכר שהפרדתי את הפקודה הזאת פעם אחת
כי
רצנו
אעשה הרחבה מאוד
ו
באיזה מקום ראיתי
ש
שוכב חייל
פצוע קשה מאוד,
הראש שלו היה פתוח וזה היה נורא
עבורכם את הראש ואמרת עזוב את זה,
עצרתי
וחבל שנייה
ואחרי זה מה? לא,
לא חשבתי שהוא יחיה.
אחרי זמן קצר אני מסתובב בתל אביב,
אני הולך תשעה
אם אחרי על 'חוות
אני מתקרב
אל
הכלי הן שלי
שתאמר
אז כמו שכבר הרווחתי את היום עבודה
חוץ מהקרב הזה, שחרוט היטב בזיכרון חיינו. עוד
קרבות
תראה, זה איך זה היתה
הקטע הזה
היה קרב אחרי קו קו רו.
אני אפילו לא זוכר מעט
מהקודם.
אתם גם נכנסתם לסינה, המשכתם אחרי זה לתוך סיני
בחג
אחר.
אז איפה אתה הגעת הכי הכי רחוק? בשיא
אני
כן.
אני ממש לא יכול לציין
כי לא הייתי באנרגיה גבוהה.
כן,
מי יודע מה.
אז התוכניות. וזה,
אתה זוכר?
אתה היית מהכוח ש
היא
נסעה מערבה למלחמה
כינסו לשם יציאת צה ל שוטר ג'קי
אני יודע.
אני ממש לא זוכר, זיק.
ולכוון ללארי שאתה גם הייתה בכוח
כן עליכן,
בלי להרגיש כי
וזה הרבה שהיתה כשאתם מקבלים הוראה לסגת מסיני
כן
כל מה ש בסוף המלחמה
הוא פחות חרות אצלי
מפני ש
הייתי חלק מכוח גדול מאוד
תודה.
ונראה לך בדיוק
לא,
אתה היית בין אלה שיש ירדו ליום רעש רעש
גם
גם בית אומר חבר שירבוט גב גם אולם גם
כן
כן,
לספר קצת על המקצוע הזה לא זוכר לא
היה הדברים האלה אמור לנו
אני כבר הייתי
אתה
בדרגה נמוכה אתה
טוב
אז אתה היית
אתה הגעת להנפת תקן בגיל הדיון של מוות?
הייתי אבל החמצתי
כי אנחנו יצאנו באותו הזמן
שבו הן הלילה
כן,
מהסגן שומרי
מחבל
כלל
אני
כן
נו, מה שהמשורר שלנו החיים גורי
כן,
כן
כי מחפר יו זה שצילם את התמונות
ברור שמיכה נכון? נכון נכון רצינו נכון
לא
חיים גורי
טוב, אני
מסיים את המלחמה
מה לעשות?
אתה
לצבוע
כאילו אני אגיד לך
כרגע
כן
כשהסתיימה המלחמה,
אני כבר הייתי בסוף כוס מים
ובאתי ל מפקד שלי
חבר מעגן מיכאל משהו
ואן
מעגל מיכאל הגעתי הרבה אנשים כי היו שם יומיים
יו אחראית
לו
אתם ממש מפוקפק ואני זוכר
ואני אומר לא
תשמע,
אני לא, לא לא
גבריאל,
אני לא הייתי מביאה פיקוד גבוה בצבא
אין לזה שום
אני ממילא חושב להיות יומיים
כל זה?
כן.
אז תעזוב אותי, תעזוב אותי במנוחה.
זה
לא
פה ושם
לא ייתכן.
אה,
כמעט לא
תשמע חבל על הזמן,
אבל הזמן
אני לא יושב בצבא
אז אם ישתחרר עוד חודשיים או עוד
עזוב אותי, אני
דומה
נערך
ביום שנגמרה חדישה
היתה החטיבה
אחד היא אומרת,
אתה קצת מטושטש
אז
אז הוא אומר לשמוע את הגג. אמרת את זה, אתה
קאש. ומימין
זה
אם את לא
זה בדיוק מה שאני פוחד
אני לא רוצה את ללכת לקורס מ
כי אמרתי להם אני אחרי המלחמה חוזר
אז גם הקים אותי, זוכר
רפי פה המקיימים שהסוכן
אני המים מקצועי עם תעודות?
לא?
וחבל הזמן.
אני אני שכחתי את השם שלו.
ואני בטוח שזה בגלל שזה הקיבוץ ימי
לא בסוף אומרת יודע מה?
עוף לי מהעיניים.
לופטי,
מה העניין?
אה,
אז הוא אמר לי
תשמע,
אתה רוצה לצאת לחופש כולם רוצים לציית לחוק,
אז תחיי את כולם שוב.
אמרתי לו
'אני מדבר, חבר, צא. לא,
אני לא מבלבל ת'מוח.
אני לא מתכוון לי שהוא בזה ואעזוב.
בסדר? איפה הוא
הזכיר
ואמר לי אופנים מהעניין,
אני אומר לי, אבל אתה
שלום, הומר.
לא,
לא. שלום, אף אחד.
הנה לך אבטחה.
ביום שאני על זה אני פה.
אני אפילו לא נושא הבית.
זאת
אני נוסע ישר
בחיפה ועולה על אונייה
מצאתי לך איפה
ובדיוק
היית עמדה להפליג אונייה
וידע לאפלה גלן
למה זה חשוב?
כי באנגליה
לחיים
תקן של אונייה זה חלק מ
מהנאמר מ
מכושר השיט שלך
בשעה הדברים כתוב מצובה תיתקל אחת
ואמרי בדקו
אונייה שהגיע
אז בסדר הגיעה אבל היא לא יכולה להפליג
ו
ויסקי
עם את לא
מילה של כבוד
יצאתי
כן
הייתי עם הדרך תפסתי טרמפ
איכשהו הגעתי לחיבה
בדיוק צריכים אוניה
האוניה היא לא יכלה להפליק
היה חסר למעלה
אמרתי תודה
אז עליתי על האונייה הזאת אבל הספקתי לטלפן לו
להגיד לא עליתי עכשיו על אוניה
לא הייתי בבית
מילה השונות
טוב
מי זה היה?
אתה שומעים מעגן מיכאל? כן,
כל הימים
טוב,
אז אתה אומר לא נהיה איך העולם נהיה
גרומיט
לאומי
דרומית דרומית
לבגדד
סינג ורצים הייתה רוצים כבר רצה
ו
הייתי עליך שנתיים
שנתיים רצוף
הייתי רב מהלך, יו שלנו
ישר
דבר מערכים לוגית,
התקדמת.
עליתי עליה
ואחת הבעיות של היה שלא היה לרב המלחים.
אז קרא לי
על
הקמפיין שלה
חלקכן ידידים גדולים.
ותשמע
אין תואר מלאכים.
אני ממנה אותך לרב מלאכים
לא בגלל שאתה כל כך טוב
בגלל שכל הכי יותר גרועים.
אני לא בסדר.
לא אכפת לי מי זה, טוב
כל הצוות הישראלי לא
קרוב.
זה היו איטלקים.
איך יווני או שניים
זה
צי סוחר?
אני אומר
נגמר. אם אתה שנתיים אתה לא קצת יותר כסף?
איך
הסדר
לסכן? זאת אומרת
מפליגים וכמה זמן בחוף לעומת
תראה אז? אז אני הייתה עומד
מנמל
הרבה יותר. משך היום
שבוע שבועיים בנושא?
לא.
וזה היה כאן?
חיפה? לונדון?
לא. אה,
לא, לא. זה היה זה וכל מילי
היו
שתיים שלוש אוניות.
אז כל מי הייתה נוסעת את כל הנמלים זה
נסיע את החצי שנה או משהו כזה?
כן.
חצי שעה
עכשיו כולם
בערך. אני לא
יודע
איך היו התנאים. האונייה
ברב מהלכים.
זה היה אומר לך אם זה
אני בנפט. הקבינה שלי לבד.
זו הייתה אונייה
אם הייתי רואה את הדרומית לא הייתה מאמין שיש אניות כאלה.
זה אוניית מאיטים כזאת.
ואז ועניתי להכווין. אני
הייתי מבסוט שם. אהבתי את ה
מה זה נקרא? בלי את הקבינה. לא היתה כוונה. לא היה כל ההר קטעים.
זה היה מגורי הצוות יהיה מחולק ל כבד.
אז גם אני בניתי. לי.
כן.
אז במשך שנתיים,
אתה יותר משנתיים אתה מפליק לריו. מהלכים. מתי אתה נכנס
להיות פה
לפוליטיקה
עכשיו,
אדם. למשל, איך נתפוס הג'וק הזה אותך עוד
התחילו אלה.
היה לנו סכסוך קטן
קטן על משהו אני יודע.
ו
אז הרוצח עבד
בעבר. זה לא עבד.
אז בחור אותי דבר.
ו
והייתי גם רב מלאכים גם בוועד
הקפטן שם
היה
מעקב טילים הראשונים של הצי
היהודי גרמני
כשהיה בגרמניה. חבר המפלגה הקומוניסטית.
זה
לכן בתוך ש
ביחסים שלי איתו
היו מיוחדים כאלה. כן,
ו
ילדים אחר כך הוא
הצפים.
מה היה שמו?
איפה אמא?
כן,
תודה.
חבל. בגלל
אוקיי, אז התחיל זה
התחיל לסכסוך קטן באיזו בעיה קטנה והתבלט
הפך להיות דבר
קיבלת דיבון של ההיסטוריה.
תראה,
לא רק שלא קיבלתי
אלה הם
שם התחיל. אתה שאלת עליו
שם?
אני גיליתי חיש קל
כשהרב אמיתי שזה יסתדר.
ההסתדרות הייתה באותה תקופה
היה שם. איזה מין?
אני לא רוצה להגיד תחילה, כי זה לא יפה, אבל היה איזה
פוץ כזה
כשהוא היה
ערב מלאכים, אבל הוא הבין בזה פחות ממך.
זה
כלומר מה הוועד מזה ווד יש הסתדרות ושק כל ההסתדרות.
את לא בסדר. אבל ההסתדרות זה
זה
בשביל אנו למדינה,
להתקהלות ללמד אותי לפסיכולוג.
וזה גם היה הפגישה הראשונה שלי. מה הם הגורם הזה?
כל מי שהיה בצי
הישראלי באותה תקופה. תגיד לו משה גולן סטו יפה.
זה איך
באמת תחילה, ממש
ימין.
אולם הזה היה משטרת המשמעת,
לא? וועד העובדים מלווה.
ואז למדתי לקח איך
מה הם יחסי הכוחות
ואז התחילה התסיסה הילה התחילה המשיכה
וכולם ידעו את זה
שמישהו עומד מורנו
וזה עבד
זה לא
לא, זה ההסתדרות זה לא עבד
זה
אוקיי,
אבל אל הים האם בהסתדרות, בהסתדרות
אז החלטנו
מהמקום הייתה אסיפה והוא
צריך לבחור ועד
ואז התחיל כל העיר
במה זה התבטא
שה מייצגים שלכם בהסתדרות בעצם לא יזכו אתכם בע מ זה יתבטא ביום יום
בכל דבר הכי קטן
הכי קטן
למשל
אתן לך דוגמה שאני מכיר את זוכרת
זו הייתה אונייה מאוד השנה
אמרנו צריך לצרחות מיכל אחד
עם מה? עם מי שתיה מהכביסה זה
כל היה מלא חלודה
מי זה התחיל?
מה פתאום
איזה ופה ושם אתם מסיתים
והתחיל לעשות אולי עשו לי שם של
קרב מייקר ואלה
והשאר 'לאזלו' הם כתובים
כמו שכתוב אנחנו רוצים לשמוע אני מבקש לשמוע
אז אתה
מתמנה, אתה בוועד של האונייה
כנראה שקורה רב המלחים
בסדר, אומר לך
אחר כך אבל גם בחור
וטוב עד
אז, נכון?
אז
מהר מאוד אני הבנתי מה שכולם הבינו
ש
מה
המכשול הזה?
הו לרוכב כל הדרך אם לא ניפטר ממנו.
ואז התחיל הסכסוך. ידוע
ש
פסגתו שמיטה את הים
אז אתה יורד לחוף,
יורד פה. אנחנו לא נעשה בתקופה בין המפלגות אני מבין
כן, אבל הייתי שנתיים. רב מלאכים שם ממש כן, ברור.
אז
מתי מתי אמא
שגם להחלטה אצלך? כשאתה מתחיל לנהל מאבק נגד הנציגות הזאת שלכם בהסתדרות
אני לא הייתי זה לא היה תלוי בי.
זה לא חיכה ליוזמה. מתי
זה היה שם
והיא
התחילה להסית נגדו
הסתיימה זה מלוכלכת
ומה לא יאשימו.
אבל זה לא כל כך תפס כי בכל זאת לא נולדתי אתמול.
אפשר לעשות ממני גנגסטר וגנב.
ואז התחילה הסכסוך הזה ש
פסגתו זה שביתת היומיים
אחת השווית אותה?
שש שנים רבות הזכירו אותך
וזה היה
קורס התנגשות.
זה לא היה
משהו שהוא
התחילו להסית נגדי. אז התחיל את
זה. אז דיברו עליהם
דיון היום.
מה שלא תגיד כן.
גנב אנס
מרגל
מעשר אגורות זה
כן,
אני. מי היה בחבורה המובילה אצלכם? אף אחד מהם לא חי. אחד חי
מזה
חיים צוקר.
ומי עוד היה קצת איטי? מת. שמותיהן שלנו שיהיה.
הייתי מניח
חזיתו
קיבלתי
את
חבורה.
שניהם קצת יותר ותיקים
ש
זה היה ברור לנו אבל
מהר מאוד גם לציבור
ש
החלוקה היא לא כמו שאנחנו חושבים.
כן,
אני
היינו היו טענות שיש פה שהייתה
פה אשרה הקומוניסטית
בון שהתלוו
לו דובאל לא היה אפילו אחד
להגיד בקבוצה גדולה יכול להיות לא
היו אנשי ימין גם אנשים מכירות
שלו את עצמם מחויבים.
הו,
לא.
לא היה לזה אפילו
זה התחיל ככה שלא הכירו בכם.
כן, נבחר. כן.
גארי סאיטו הבאה. ולמה קרן אוקיי
יסיטו. ואם
זה היה
משהו
שלא יכול היה להימשך
לימים,
כשנעשה את ידית של אלמוגים,
היינו ידידים בימות, בלינות. כי הוא
אז הוא אומר לי שזה
אם אם הוא עשה טעות בחייו,
זה שהוא לא הבין שזה
הנציגים האותנטיים ולא
הייתה המעורבות של השב כ ב
אני מניח שכן, אבל אני לא יודע אם
אתה לא יודע השתילו אצלכם?
בטוח שכן. מה זה אז? אבל
זה היה
מובן מאליו.
אז איך
אני זה רק אתם פותחים בשביתה על רקע של
הטבת דיה
ביער? שירות
התחיל מזה. אבל מהר מאוד ראינו שהמשטרה נגדנו זה אבל שלנו
הם התחילו להסית נגדנו.
וזה אחת אתה עובדת שגם אלמוג יהודה
אומר אני לא יודע,
לא תיארתי לי
כן, ברגע שצריכים להגיד שאנחנו מרגלים ושאנחנו שוחח מקום אינטרנט,
אני אפילו לא יודע
מה זה בקומינטרן תרמילים
אז יתחלק בצורה אחרת ממה שהם צריכים
ויתקיימו בחירות.
ואנחנו היינו בטוחים שאנחנו מספקים את הימים,
אבל לא תיארנו לנו
אני די בודד על זה שפתחת הקלפי.
הם לא קיבלו אפילו את מספר האנשים
שעבדו בה מזכירות של האיגוד.
אנחנו קיבלנו
פסיק רישא אחוז.
זה היה ב הוא כבר שזה
לא איזה
ואז
אבל לומר שכן
הגבול
לא היה.
לא היה ברור?
זה
מהר מאוד
האלה ש
הציגו את עצמם כאילו שהם זבל. אנחנו לפעמים
לזה בכלל מקום יותר זה ספר. הם לא קיבלו
יותר משניים שלושה קולות.
אז
מתי
אתם החלטתם
מתי ובאיזו צורה החלטתם שאתם פותחים בשביתה להטבת
ולהכרה בכם
כאב אדיר
תיכף הוא
זאת אומרת,
למעשה האזין ומייד
מיד.
אבל זה לקח קצת זמן
עד שהתברר
של הצד השני. בכל זאת, אין מה לעשות. אין להם כמו
תומכים
אפילו מיעוט ש במיעוט.
שום דבר.
ו
אז פרצה השביתה שהייתה
בעיר לחמישה היום,
מושכת.
והם כולם אפוא כולם.
לא היה להם שום אחיזה
ולא הייתה בהם אפילו תועלת לא ייתן להם שום תמיכה.
וההסתדרות העדינה
שהיא מאבדת
את פה איגוד רציני מאוד.
אז
הם שולחו
והמטפל
בענייני הימים מטעם ההסתדרות מוחלף.
וזה היה ברעש.
ואז
עד מהרה
הוא פשוט הבין שזה לא מה שהיה מולו.
איך הם היו
כומר?
מאז ועד היום בבית שקט ושלווה
היו ניסיונות לסגור את השביתה שלכם.
כן, אבל שכחו רק דבר אחד
שאהב. האם זה לא בוגרי קורס גננות?
כי זה פלוגות הפועל עם המקלות והם על זה.
אנחנו
אחרי
ההתנגשות הראשונה
כשעברנו להם את העצמות
ובזה זה נגמר
פשוט בא כוח
אומר
מה היה חלקו של אבא חושי
לבחוש ואז כבר לא היה
מזכיר מועצת
הולכת
לראש העיר?
כן,
אזוקה
מינימום ה
כן,
אבל לא היה לו שום משקל
פשוט שהוא משקל
מזכיר המועצה
זה האוסף אלמוגי.
יוסף אלמוגי
היה איש
שלו? לא,
הוא לא היה עדין נפש, והוא
הוא חשב שהוא ילך בכוח
ותיכף וההתנגשויות ולשנות
בצורה כוח.
לא
היתה לכם פגישה עם
הדרג המיניסטריאלי?
כן,
בן גוריון שלח את נאמנות
אה,
כן. כשאני אומר נאמנות כי זה היה הכל, לא היה לו שום דבר אחר.
הוא זה שהיה נאמן לבן גוריון
שהוא לא ואיגור.
אז שוב אביגור באימא,
הדגל ש
הנה אפוא נגדנו
עם הדגל של הכוח וזה
אבל מה על זכותו, אם בכלל יש לו זכויות
כשהוא תפס מהר ש
אין פה אי בהירות או אומר יש הימים מצד אחד
והממסד מצד שני.
אה, למה
זה תעש גאה שהוא גם
אמר כי
הוא קצת קרוב שלי. אז
כן, רציתי לשאול מה קירבת
משפחה שלכם זה שינה קצת
כי ערוץ נוסף
מחוץ לרפורמה.
תראה, כשאתה פוגש בן משפחה
זה אומר שהם טעו וחשבו ש
הם עצמם האמינו למה שהם
תפיצו.
אבל זה מלכתחילה היה חסר כל סיכוי
אחרי ש
היו הבחירות
מתברר שאנחנו קיבלנו
מאה אחוז מהכל. אם
אתה מוצא
את
הפסיקה,
אז אין הרבה מה לי תעסוקה
ואז זה מחיר אשם במשהו
אומרת אחת המכונות
חושב
שאול אביגור חזר לשולחן.
כלומר, אם אנחנו רוצים
שיהיה לנו אני לא יודע. לרוב לא וזה, אבל שיהיה לה מעמד בין הימאים.
אנחנו לא יכולים להתעלם
מהמצב.
הם מייצגים את
רוב, היה מהיר
והוא היה ממש
והטוב שלנו.
אלא מה?
הוא היה חבר הוועד הפועל.
אוקיי,
תודה.
זה היה
רק
כל פעם שאני שומע את הביטוי הזה,
בן גוריון של בארץ הם היו
איפה
הם באו אלינו
ו במשך כמה חודשים
ניהלנו משא ומתן,
הוציא אותנו מהצבא.
הייתי הוא בא
לפגישות עם מדי צה.
אני אחרי כוס ממנה
הייתי ב כבר אז שבע שנים ב פלומה.
קחו, הכניסו אותנו ל
רק בן גוריון
יכול
אני פה,
חי קצת באי ודאות לגבי
מתי היא אומרת הימים.
מתי
אלבז
באת? די במדעי. צבעת. את
אמרת אני הייתי בסוף.
לא,
בן גוריון גייס אותנו.
אם היה לי, אם הייתם ב למעשה, מגויסים ציין. שוכן בה את הזרועות
היו
של אנשים מגויסים. כולם היו מגוהצים,
לא היה ברור לו. לא חשבתי את זה.
כן,
זה גם כן
תפסו את זה.
פרק בפני עצמו
ש
מה? לראש ממשלה בכלל בסכסוך עבודה.
הוא הוציא לנו זה
שלח כמה מכוניות עם משטרה צבאית
ולקחו אותנו ביום בהיר אחד
ויביא אותנו שרפה
בזמן, אומרת בזמן השביתה. כן,
כמה זמן הייתם בסערה?
נעשה באופן והיינו
זה
גמרנו את הטירונות
וחולק. נו, בין כל חילוץ ערד,
עם פיקוח אישי של מזון,
כשיודעים
יודעים. לולא כל יום
והוא כל הזמן, אבל תגידו לי איך הם בורחים.
היו הופענו בכל הארץ
לאכול
והציבור היה
לצידינו, אחרת זה לא היה קורה.
אז כמה זמן היית, אבל
לא בתחום
בשר.
אמרתי איזה טירונות של אחותי לתותחנים.
אז אתם בעצם גויסתם. אתה מחויב
אבל באופן בלתי חוקי,
כי מנהל יזרעאל כבר היתה אז מדינה מסודרת,
והצבא לא לוקחים כל משלו.
זה אחד,
והדבר השני
זה כשהוא
נתן הוראה
לשחרר אותנו למשא ומתן
גם כן בלתי חוקי.
אבל בינינו הוא
לא רק בגלל החוק כמו שמספרים לנו.
מי נתן לכם בעיתונות
את התמיכה
הכי גורפת? מי הלך אתכם? בעיקר באותו מהפעם ומייקל,
אבל מה היא היתה כוח קטן מאוד
ולא מרשים. אז
פעם היתה החבית מפני שוב.
אז איך לסיים? כל הסיפור של המאה
שדרת הימים ברחוב
הוא
יש שתי גירסאות
טעימה אחת. המציאות
באחד הסיבובים של בן אור שובר את שביתתם,
לא, לא שובש, וזה
הוציא את עצמו מהעסק
שלח את שוליו איגור
ואתה לא.
אז שווי גור מהר מאוד פשוט תפס
ש
אין דבר כזה
במאה העשרים
אה,
איגוד מקצועי בלי ועד בלי מוסדות.
אז
זה היה
כשסיימתי את
השליטה הגדולה הזאת. הייתה כשסיימתי. הייתה של תקופה באונייה הראשונה שלך בדרומי?
כן.
אחרי שאתה מסתיים כל פעם לסיים את הפרשה הזו אתה חוזר לים? כמובן.
ומה עכשיו?
עכשיו אני בפנסיה.
לא, לא עכשיו. עכשיו, עכשיו אני אומר לך מישהי
כן, כן
איפה אתה עולה על
אניות אחרות? כן,
זה למשל
הבאים שעה הייתי קפטיין,
בוא תספר קצת. איך אתה
אין בית ספר. זה העבודה של קמפר רגילה או לא,
הייתי בכל הקטע
לוגי. אתה ישבת לך
לא לספר. אתה הוא
ממשיך קרב מלאכים. או,
כן,
והוא
מתכונן
לבחינות
לקצונה.
אבל למדתי לבד כי לא היה קורס. וזה,
אה
ואז חזרתי להפליל בתוכך את סין.
די נדיר שאתה עובר עושה את זה. הלימודי. קצונה,
לוזר אבו כך לא להגיד לו גם לקמפיין
גם
כן.
אז על איזון. יעתרו לי אחרי
השביתה הגדולה.
משהו
חייב. זה לא חשוב.
האוניה הראשונה שהייתה צריכה לחלקכם שלך מכובה.
אז אתה הופך להיות קצין
שני ראשון לשאול
כן,
כן
וכן.
מה?
על
מה אתה זוכר החלק הקשה ביותר בתפקיד הזה
ביום ההוא היינו לך
אתגרים קשים. היו לך.
לא היה לו. לא
היה לי ממש
עשיתי חיים.
ממש לא.
אתה יודע, רוב החיים עשיתי חיים.
לא,
לא היה שום דבר
מיוחד.
מה גולת הכותרת שאתה רואה בה?
מה התפקיד שלך
לאחר מד היה
מרד הימאים.
רישום
כי המים את הפכת להיות גם מוכן. ומה מספיק טוב?
אני עברתי את כל הדרגות.
היי, אמירות.
וגם
בתקופות שונות
אדמיניסטרטיבי
טבעיות, ממשלתיות
אדיתי מנהל הריר במשך כמה שנים
מנהל אגף הספנות והנמלים.
או,
זה הכל? זה הבחינות והכל.
ואחד חזרתי להפעיל
להפליג בים סתם
כי קפטיין,
וכשבא יהיו שם, אלו לשבעים במקרה,
האונייה הגיעה ל חיפה.
הודעתי שאני
מוציא את עצמי ל
פנסי. אני יודע
וזהו.
לא
יישוב
שום דבר מיוחד.
איזו? מי יכין
סכו עליך? טוב, ככה תהיה. הייתי על כל סוגי הבנייה.
הייתי
גם על אוניות נוסעים, שזה
זה
הייתי גם
על היו שתי לביצי הסוכר
הישראלי היו שתי אוניות חיוורות
ויש שתי המיכליות הכי גדולות שנבנו אי פעם
כ
אלף טון.
זה
עומד על הגשר.
אתה צריך במשקפת, לראות אם יש אנשים על החרטום.
וזה
זה משהו.
זה משהו
זה גם ההרגשה, אתה יודע
לעבור את מיצרי טירן
ש מכל צד, נשאר לך כמה מטר. זה לא פשוט.
זה היו שתי המיכליות עכשיו מיכליות שהיית נוסע מפר מאיראן
לקץ על ושל כן, כן, כן לורי לתת כן לכמחצית. כן, כן,
כן.
היו לך איזה אירועים חריגים ב
הכל שם אחרים.
אתה תספר איזה חריגה
להבא אני יודע, זה תשמע
בקו הזה
זה כל הזמן אותו דבר. זה נעשה. הפלגות עוזרים הפלגות
כמה זמן היה סבב כזה? שלי
בני אדם? איפה? זה היה בעיה בדם?
לא, לא. זה היה מילת
ל
להיות את.
היו כמה כמה מנמנם
במפרץ הפרסי
שלום.
כמה זמן היה נמשך סבב כזה שוב? קאמבר?
כן,
חלק.
יש לך משהו לשאול? עובד אצלם כמה תמונות,
אבל
בחינות אירוע היין
יש בעיתונים. אבל יש לך יש הרבה עיתונים.
מה
הוא לצלם,
אורליוס?
בסדר, אבל
אני רוצה
לדעת
תבוא תגיד כמה מילים
בבקשה.
כל תמונה. מה יש? רשום להם לא התמונות האלה
כל
הנה זה פה.
תודה.
תודה, תודה
כן
הלו?
מה
טוב
הכל
מובן
מאליו.
אוקיי
ביי.
כן לירות
גם התמונות כשעכשיו
זה המרפק
שלי שבגלל שהוא יישאר פה בואו נדבר מפה אנחנו?
אתה רואה את התמונות נתלו?
כן
שנייה אני ככה
בסדר
תודה
טוב
כן נשמע מהמיקרופון הזה
למיקרופון
בו אז זה המי האלו
זוכר את השמות שלהם
היום
מי ייתן
זה יעבוד
כן
יו
הוא היה מצייר אותן
כמודלים לוקח צילום ועליו
מודל